[Applaudissements]
c'est pas grave au fond l'été ont
séjourné j'ai des gros projets estivaux
qui avait besoin de cette coupe la wii
si je peux me permettre on aimerait bien
avoir le nom de votre coiffeuse parce
que c'est super bien fait je sais pas
comment elle a fait des maliens des
doublons comme ça c'est génial on
s'appelle elodie elle est magnifique
voilà on allait faire deux fois j'aurai
voilà cabossé par un volume 30
et c'est bon on n'est pas chez les
coiffeurs et sexies rdc sur paris cédric
6 heures une grande chaîne sur paris ça
fait servir un joueur de foot du psg
allah allah vous rajeunissez incroyable
rio oui c'est quand est ce que tu vas tu
moshé bas pc sur le coup ça m'irait bien
koné lakou mais bon bah c'est ben ali
merci mais non merci
oui là où déçus comme ça sur un ton
léger et sur un ton badin on se rend pas
compte que cela vous êtes en train d'en
c'est la tendance et cet été tous les
jeunes on va vous sur les plages de
[Musique]
47 on a plein de choses à faire j'aime
bien avant qu'elle faisait mais bien
alors c'est non merci